[Music]
looking to
get your beach body into shape
ready to lose that excess weight
well our new patented diet plan is for
you
today we're going to get rid of your
skeleton
you don't need your bones right
what would your boneless lifestyle be
like
how would you eat without jaw jawbones
and is your skeleton still evolving
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we didn't have any bones
okay brace yourself we just got the
results in
and we're sorry to report that you've
got a spooky
scary skeleton inside of you
your skeletal system is made up of bones
tendons ligaments and cartilage
it produces blood cells stores and
releases
fats and minerals and you know supports
the structure
of your body but don't worry we're gonna
take that sucker right out in fact we're
taking
everyone's bones out you don't need to
thank us
we're just trying to do our part wanna
know something
i'm a bad doctor
so what would your new boneless life
be like well you wouldn't be able to
move
for starters have you ever wanted to
spend the whole day
in bed well now you can
every day don't worry
it's perfectly fine just take a breath
just take a deep breath
but not too deeply because without a rib
cage
your lungs wouldn't be able to expand
without
bones you would need to be hooked up to
a ventilator 24
7. this means you would be subject to
more infections because
your airways are always open
[Music]
this would let all sorts of nasty germs
in
for example a common cold would quickly
become
pneumonia but as long as you
eat healthy you should be okay
well when i said eat i meant we'd give
you a feeding tube
you can't chew without your jaw bones
on the bright side you wouldn't have any
bone related diseases
like osteoporosis plus you'd never have
to worry about
wearing a cast but
what if our bones weren't removed
what if we never had them in the first
place
if we had evolved without bones
that might mean that we would never have
left the ocean and
we lived our lives like human jellyfish
maybe we would evolve to have an
exoskeleton
[Music]
then we would need to mold and grow
bigger exoskeletons
as we grew
okay i'll be honest that sounds pretty
gross but
the good news is is that you wouldn't
have to deal with it for long
yeah your lifespan would decrease
significantly
since your skeleton provides much needed
protection for your organs
your brain would be left without its
helmet making your noggin
extremely vulnerable okay maybe this
wasn't the best idea our bones do
more than we give them credit for we
already know that
our bones grow with us as we get older
but
did you know that modern life is
actually causing our bones to
change for example feel the back of your
head
on the back of your skull is a
spike-like feature called the
external occipital protuberance
but it wasn't always there
in fact it used to be so rare that
we didn't start investigating it until
1885.
so where did it come from
well get this the spike is most common
in younger people
the reason technology
the constant use of smartphones and
tablets
has led to this spike since we're
hunched over our devices
it causes strain on our necks this
protuberance
helps the skull cope with the extra
stress because
it spreads the weight over a wider area
so basically your skeleton is looking
out for you
ah thanks bones but you don't have to
worry about it
chances are that if you're watching this
video
you have a skeleton but that
isn't necessarily the case there's a
rare genetic disorder called
hypophosphatasia that affects one
out of every 100 000 babies
it's a disorder that causes your bones
to
disappear patients with this disorder
lack an enzyme called alkaline
phosphatase
this causes their bones to be extremely
fragile so
they break down easily
thankfully as of today doctors are
working on
special enzyme treatments these allow
the bones to slowly grow back so
patients can move again so
to sum it all up your bones are
extremely important without
bones in your body you wouldn't live
long at all
and to be honest you should make an
effort to take care of that skeleton of
yours
get it tibia honest is a bone joke like
the tibia whatever
but with all this talk about short life
spans
what if that was the norm what if
you went from being a newborn to your
deathbed
in a day what if you only lived for
24 hours well
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you